ich habe immer noch nicht gehört warum
wie dieses unsäglich schreckliche person
getan hat
in einem moment da mal im moment ganz
ruhig philipp so würde man mit einem
pferd ein buch über das leben und die
liebe mit und zu werden
ich habe im juli zeh schon immer für ein
zeichen dessen gehalten was falsch läuft
mit unserer kultur und ich bin nahezu
fassungslos wie extrem einem der kitsch
nochmal hier entgegen trifft zum
beispiel eine vorliebe für so wende und
die hand aufs herz
aber du hast ja aufnehmen sagte meine
ganz wichtig finde ich es noch zu
betonen dass oder was sage ich immer
gesagt so ziemlich oft also vielleicht
darf ich erwähnen dass ich ja schon
immer juli zeh sehr gerne gelesen habe
ich habe mir dann plötzlich so gedacht
statt dieses flöten mädchen zu sein oder
dieses tennis mädchen okay ich war ich
möchte noch gerne serien von dem
persönlichen einbettung noch mal kurz
darauf gebiet raum gibt es dieses buch
natürlich muss man glaube ich pferde
mädchen sein um sich mit einer
gebrauchsanweisung für pferde zu
befassen es geht nicht um pferde in
diesem buch es geht um juli 10 hallo ihr
verhältnis zu werden als sonst in der
bild darüber zu station des menschen am
medium fährt nein das tut es nicht dass
du das bin ich schon ähnlich wie pferde
besitzen auch pferde mädchen feinster
antennen für rang unterschiede
juli zehs soziologie der pferde mädchen
auch noch mit dieser schiefen metapher
ok und das auch kein problem mit dieser
ganzen schilderung der pferde mädchen
dynamik und das und das mädchen nach
vorne kommen
ich hab doch wie gesagt ich bedaure dass
ich kein pferde mädchen war das wäre es
auch schön gewesen dann will ich jetzt
nicht sagen dass du dieses buch gut
findet ich will mir jetzt bitte nicht
sagen weil das würde mich auch nicht
eine der unendlich trivialen botschaften
dieses unendlich trivialen buch ist ist
dass pferde uns helfen im moment zu
leben ich wusste zum beispiel nicht dass
juli zeh war an der ökologischen
akademie und es kehrte flüstern und das
müssen wir wissen einfach die frage
warum es dieses buch gibt wir werden
jetzt vielleicht zuschriften bekommen
aber
möchte gerne noch mal festhalten dass
pferde nicht nur fluchttiere sind
sondern jetzt auch nicht die hellsten
der kvc schreiben was sie will aber er
werde sind wesentlich weniger
intelligent als zb can oder kranken
affen ja von affen gar nicht zu reden
[Musik]